today the Matt wall show John fetterman
delivers the worst debate performance in
American history but his
self-destruction is not solely his own
fault the blame also lies with the
Democrat Party and also his wife I'll
explain why also the Governor of New
York humiliates herself in her debate as
well not quite as bad as fetterman but
almost and chest mutilation procedures
on minors have risen by 400 percent in
the last few years plus we'll hear from
a Hungarian politician who explains why
they don't have that problem in their
own country and Bono discovers to his
horror that maybe free market capitalism
isn't so bad after all all of that and
more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
foreign
what are your family's values Faith
Church on Sunday does your family
believe in serving did you vaccinate
your kids or did you say I don't think
so how does your family Define men and
women what kind of value do they put on
life your children they look to you to
Define their values and their
perspectives of the world but what if
you weren't here to do that for them in
the event that you die who will ensure
the values you hold dear are upheld by
your kids epic will can help with that a
will let you determine who will raise
your kids in the event that you die
before you're done raising them this is
a big deal and it's your your
responsibility as a parent
it's why we at the daily wire have
partnered with Epic Wheel take five
minutes a day go to epicworld.com use
promo code Walsh to save 10 on Epic
Wheels complete will package but more
importantly uh you got to do this so
that I know that you did it so that
you're accountable to me so that I know
that you took this crucial step towards
doing the right thing and taking care of
your family I know who you are I will be
checking I am watching epicwill.com
promo code Walsh no excuses go there now
get it done
well over the centuries many historians
anthropologists social critics have
pointed to certain signs that a
civilization is about to collapse
various lists of red flags are you know
usually pretty similar population
decline War economic instability Mass
uncontrolled migration moral Decay Etc
otherwise known to contemporary
Americans as just your average Wednesday
but it seems that these observers have
all missed one major alarm Bell along
with all the other symptoms just listed
a society is in Decline and on the verge
of catastrophe
if it starts electing brain damage
people to lead it
the future is probably not very bright
for a country that looks to uh you know
those with severe mental defects for
political leadership it is a it is a
subtle sign of cultural dysfunction and
by subtle I mean that it's a flashing
blaring siren with a bright neon sign
that says danger in huge capital letters
it's already too late of course to steer
entirely clear of this particular Hazard
for you know in our case we have a
senile dementia patient in the White
House not to mention a mummified Speaker
of the House
and now Democrats in Pennsylvania are
looking to add to Washington DC's
burgeoning neurology Ward by electing a
stroke victim who literally cannot
understand human language or speak it
last night Senate candidates John
fetterman and Dr Oz faced each other in
the first and mercifully for fetterman
only Pennsylvania debate it was uh in
fetterman's case a performance that in
the year 2022 could be described I guess
as presidential to steal a joke from Ann
Coulter that she tweeted this morning uh
fetterman could barely string a coherent
thought together even even before the
stroke you could barely do that but then
afterwards it's a whole other deal I
mean there's no hope at all the debate
was destined then to be a train wreck
and yet Against All Odds the disaster
managed to exceed everyone's
expectations it was worse than we
thought it would it was as though there
was a train wreck and then an airplane
crashed right into the site of the train
wreck and then a tornado came through
followed by an earthquake followed by a
wildfire it was in other words the worst
debate performance ever captured on film
in the history of American politics and
that is still somehow I think an
understatement so the clips have already
circulated wildly widely on social media
there's probably no need to play them
now
but we will anyway
um things started awkwardly enough with
fetterman saying hello to the audience
and goodbye in the same breath
what qualifies you to be a U.S senator
you have 60 Seconds
hi good night everybody
I'm running to serve Pennsylvania he's
running to use Pennsylvania here's a man
that spent more than 20 million dollars
of his own money to try to buy that seat
I'm also having to talk about something
called the Oz rule that if he's on TV
he's lying he did that during his career
on his TV show he's done that during his
campaign about lying about
our record here and he's also lying
probably during this debate
well it was only downhill from there
though I will say that his greeting
reminds me of myself anytime my wife
forces me to go to a party hi everyone
good night okay let's go home honey
let's go but I'm usually forced to stay
there for much longer than I prefer and
fetterman was in the same situation the
debate only lasted an hour but fetterman
couldn't make it more than 90 seconds
before the full-on collapse began so
here he is trying to explain his plan to
make higher education more affordable
how exactly Mr fetterman do you propose
doing that to make it more affordable
for a fact for families
no I I just believe I just making it
that much more it it costs too much and
I believe providing the resources to
reduce the tuition to allow families to
be able to afford it
good point and here he is on uh the
minimum wage listen
and how can a man you know with with you
know 10 gigantic Mansions you know has
am willing to talk about a willing wage
for anybody imagine a signal Mom trying
with two children trying to race with
them realizing making Thirty one
thousand dollars a year you know fifteen
dollars an hour
you know those signal bombs you've got
to watch out for the signal moms so you
probably get the idea
um there was one other moment uh the
moment that still managed to stand out
as a specially embarrassing even amid
all of that when Federman was asked to
explain his flip-flopping stance on
fracking here's what he said
Mr Oz I do want to clarify something
you're saying tonight that you support
fracking that you've always supported
fracking but there is that 2018
interview that you said quote I don't
support fracking at all so how do you
square the two
oh I I I do support fracking and
I don't I don't
I support fracking and I stand and I do
support fracking
well that clears that up now
where do the Democrats go from here
their guy not fit to be in the U.S
Senate not fit to be anywhere really
except in bed at home recovering and
everyone can see that now it was put on
display for the whole country to see
last night do they acknowledge this
plain reality and let the chips fall
where they may no of course not because
acknowledging reality has never been a
favorite pastime of the left rather
their favorite pastime as we know is
playing the victim card and they were
quick on the draw after this debate Liz
plank is a left-wing pundit who was one
of the many blue checks on Twitter to
repeat this agreed upon talking point
she tweeted Dr Oz just gave a master
class on how to bully people with
disabilities
yes debating your opponent in a senate
race is now bullying
ableism has become the leftist buzzword
of the day MSNBC got that ball rolling
immediately after the debate listen to
this
one of the things you posit in your
article is that fetterman's campaign is
hoping to turn his sort of vulnerability
into an asset here do you think he did
so on the debate stage tonight I think
it's tough to say whether or not it will
wind up being an asset with voters but
it was certainly an example of such
remarkable transparency the opposite of
what what the Oz campaign has sort of
asserted which is that he's somehow
hiding something about his health I mean
showing up for an hour debate and it was
as he said starting out he he said he
was going to talk about the elephant in
the room you played the clip he said I'm
going to miss words and and you could
tell I wrote in my story about how in my
interview with him there was a moment
where he became frustrated and stressed
out and it made some of his
communicative problems worse and I think
that this context and what you described
as the insanely high stakes of this
election the single debate clearly this
was a candidate who was feeling stress
and there was such intense scrutiny
often ableist scrutiny on how he was
going to communicate and he just did a
debate in front of you know the nation
you know an audience of anyone who could
listen and it was so transparent he did
fumble he did make verbal mistakes
um you know and and it was all on view
transparent that's that's one way of
putting it I wish I'd been this clever
back when I was in like high school and
I had to bring my report cards home uh
that were never very impressive and I
like I If I had thought to couch it that
way when showing my parents listen Mom
and Dad um
I'm I'm being very I'm being remarkably
transparent with this what you can see
here let's address the elephant in the
room here okay guys
I don't study or do my homework but I'm
being transparent I'm being vulnerable
now if you expect a United States
Senator
that the United States Center should be
able to understand words and speak them
you are guilty of engaging in ableist
scrutiny we were just told indeed as the
left has explained it is not fetterman
who should drop out of the race but Dr
Oz
because anything less would be ableism
an axios article quotes a senior
Democrat official in Pennsylvania saying
this quote I wish fetterman was in a
better place to clap back overall I
argue it uh it wasn't great but for us
it was still a draw
remember in these next few weeks that
Oz's campaign is spending tens of
millions of dollars against a man with a
major medical condition
how dare Dr Oz
run campaign ads
he shouldn't be campaigning at all
fetterman has a major medical condition
which doesn't mean that he should drop
out and go home but rather that he
should be given the position out of
sympathy
that's the argument they're going with
and it's entirely consistent with the
argument they make on many other
subjects it is bigoted to acknowledge
reality in this case the reality that a
brain damaged man is not suited for the
U.S Senate
our responsibility is to deny reality
for the sake of the member of a victim
group in fact from the last perspective
if anything the stroke makes fetterman
more qualified than he was before
because before it he was just a quote
cisgender white male not a lot of victim
points now he's disabled giving him at
least a few victim points whereas
previously he had none and that's what
qualifies him
of course the whole concept of ableism
is absurd
to be ableist apparently according to
how the term is used
is simply to make judgments about what
people are able to do
and if that's what it means to be an
ableist
then we should all be ableist
an ableist person commits the sin of
being rational and realistic
of being aware of human limitations and
taking them into account
of making decisions that are grounded in
reality
believing that a person should be giving
given a job if he's best able and
qualified to perform the duties and
functions of that job this is ableism
evidently
and if it is our country needs a whole
lot more ableism of this type
and there's another point to be made
about all this
under normal circumstances you know I
would have sympathy
for somebody dealing with the aftermath
of a stroke
it is quite a sad thing to be unable to
form words unable to understand
but my sympathy in this case doesn't
extend very far because fetterman chose
to stay in the race he chose to continue
pursuing power he put himself in this
position knowing he's unsuited for it
in a similar way I have sympathy
for people with visual impairments
if simply if you're blind I I have
sympathy for blind people I wouldn't
make fun of a blind person who would
but if the pilot of an airplane has
undisclosed visual impairments
and chose to sit in the captain's chair
anyway
then my sympathy for him dries up rather
quickly because instead now I have
sympathy for the passengers in the plane
especially if I'm one of them
he has chosen to put them at the mercy
of his disability in a way that is
unfair to them
and he deserves criticism for that
harsh criticism
same goes for fetterman same goes for
Biden
they are responsible for their choices
but they're not the only ones
responsible in both cases immense scorn
should be directed at the Democrat Party
Puppet Masters who chose to keep these
guys in their positions in fact
pressured them to stay there we can
assume knowing what a disaster it would
be for them personally and more
importantly for the country
and yet their guilt pales in comparison
to the wives of both men
this to me is maybe the most important
Point here to take away from this
fetterman and Biden have lots in common
and not the least of which is the fact
that they both are married to Awful
spoiled manipulative power-hungry women
who have utterly failed to fulfill their
responsibilities as wives
Jill Biden knows better than anyone
especially if she's a doctor that her
husband is incoherent and senile she
knows that
and yet she's propped him up dragged him
along she kept him going politically so
that she could ride his coattails to the
White House
what Jill is doing is nothing less than
elder abuse I mean it should be criminal
what she's doing
and then there's fetterman's wife okay
she she should have sat her husband down
and told him that he cannot continue
she should have forced him to put his
health first
that's what a good wife does
like forced to the extent of saying you
cannot do this if you do I am not going
to be by your side I'm not going to show
up at the campaign I am not going to do
that I'm not going to go along with you
to your self-destruction
that's what a good wife would do
and every man needs a wife who will do
that even if we aren't running for
Senate we all need wives who will look
out for our health and for our
well-being even when we are not because
sometimes we don't
a man will hatch all kinds of crazy
schemes and plans some of them perhaps
brilliant but others disastrous and
self-destructive I mean we think they're
all brilliant and maybe on occasion some
of them are but then others are are very
much not and we need our wives to look
out for us just as we look out for them
though often in different kinds of
situations so a man will often need to
be the voice of reason when his wife is
getting herself into some sort of overly
emotional personal Feud or drama
um that's when a man needs to be the the
one who's there the voice of reason
talking some sense into her a woman will
often need to be the voice of reason
when her husband has come up with some
sort of insane idea that might lead to
disaster
women overreact to things men bite off
more than they can chew and they both
see the others blind spots
so together they make a formidable team
if they're both fulfilling their
obligations and loving each other in the
ways that each need to be loved
but there are men who are too weak or
too disinterested to speak up and give
their wives the guidance they need
and there are women who are too greedy
and personally ambitious to stop their
husbands from extending themselves too
far this is what is happening in
fetterman's case and in bidens
and in many other marriages across the
country
these women are not the only
manipulative women who uh you know are
are taking advantage of their husbands
hubris and stupidity
the difference is that the consequences
in their case
will be felt by the whole country
now let's get to our five headlines
all right
not at the left on the left on Twitter
we'll have some fun with some elements
of that opening monologue is my
prediction
Matt Walsh said that men should offer
guidance to their wives
gasp
yep
um okay there were more debates last
night Democrats fared poorly in all of
them like in New York where Kathy hochul
faced off against Lee zeldin um in now
in the lead before we get to this
actually the New York Times has an
article about this and about the uh
anxiety in the hokkial camp it says for
months Governor Kathy hokiel of New York
has trusted that the state's strong
Democratic majority would keep her in
office largely on the strength of a
simple message
a republican opponent was too close to
Donald J Trump and would roll back
abortion rights but just two weeks
before election day a rapidly tightening
contest has Miss hochul racing to expand
her closing argument as Democrats rarely
concede they might have misjudged
powerful fears driving the electorate
particularly around crime in just the
last few days Ms hokiel stood with mayor
Eric Adams to to announce a new flood of
police officers into the New York City
Subways she visited five Harlem churches
to assure stalwart black voters that she
was laser focused on safety and she
highlighted new statistics showing that
authorities were seizing more guns under
her watch
Miss Oakley said it one of her stops in
Harlem we believe in Justice the justice
that Jesus teaches us but it's also
about safety we are laser focused on
keeping you your children and your
grandchildren safe
her campaign has been has begun
recalibrating its paid message to
Shifting the focus of millions of
dollars in ad spending to highlight the
governor's efforts to stoke the economy
and improve Public Safety notably
including a package of modest changes to
the state's bail laws that has divided
her party changes that will do nothing
at all okay so they're they're worried
about the possibility that for the first
time in decades
um a a Statewide race could be won by a
Republican
and they're worried about it because
the state of New York and New York City
in particular is um just descending into
Anarchy
and violent crime is rising
and as it turns out and this is a
revelation for the left and for
Democrats they can't believe this they
really can't it's like they didn't see
this coming but it turns out that people
want to be safe in their communities
um
people want their children to be safe
they want to feel like their children
can walk outside without being shot and
killed they want to they want to feel as
though they can you know use public
transportation
without being assaulted or or raped or
killed by a crazed drug-addled homeless
man
what a shocker this is what people want
and and they they're they are concerned
about that far more
then they're concerned about
anything that the Democrats spend their
time talking about
transphobia and LGBT this and that
people aren't waking up in the morning
worried about that they're not they're
waking up in the morning worried about
uh
their families their kids
can they afford to feed their families
can can they afford to get put gas in
their car and go to work
are they going to be safe this is these
are the things they're worried about
so that explains the pivot to Public
Safety
which
no matter how they pivot it's it's not
going to make a difference because the
modern Democrat Party just doesn't it it
none of these people
have it in themselves to actually do
what needs to be done to address violent
crime
because making modest changes here and
there policy changes that's not going to
do anything
you know in order if you really want to
put if you really want to Tamp down
violent crime all you got to do is look
at what New York was doing
um
in the you know under Rudy Giuliani or
even Bloomberg
back when they actually had a a handle
on the violent crime epidemic
and what did you do there it's you come
down hard on the criminals
and you have to do some things that
might make people feel a little bit
uncomfortable
you know all the things that we uh that
now are anathema oh we can't do that we
can't stop and frisk we can't do any of
those things
well
you you also have to you have to come
down on the criminals
if you can
you like head them off at the pass so
you don't wait around for them to do
something so horrific and so brutal that
everyone would agree they need to be in
prison forever
you want to put them away before that
which doesn't mean that you're putting
people in prison before they commit any
crime at all
rather when someone sends a message that
they have no interest
in being a law-abiding citizen
they have no interest in being
productive members of a civilized
society when they send you that message
committing Crime After Crime After Crime
violent or otherwise
you put them away
you say to them okay we got your message
loud and clear we're gonna put you in a
cage now because you want to be an
animal and not a human being and so
unfortunately we're going to have to
give you what you have asked for
Democrats don't have it in them uh and
that was clear in the debate so there's
a couple of Clips I want to play here's
one on
where we talk about the issue of crime
and one particular phrase from hokkial
that was very interesting listen to this
this governor who still to this moment
we're not what are we halfway through
the debate she still hasn't talked about
locking up anyone committing any crimes
okay anyone who commits a crime under
our laws especially with the change we
made to bail has consequences I don't
know why that's so important you
I don't I don't know why that's so
important to you
but I just said that they really they
don't understand the Democrats they
actually don't understand why people
care about this why they want to feel
safe
and they don't she's right about that I
I believe her
she doesn't know why that's okay we'll
put violent criminals in jail if that's
so important to you
all right fine well we'll try to put
someone in a criminal in prison so they
don't uh murder another you know
innocent person walk on the street if
that's so important to you
well we know what's important to uh to
Democrats like hokkial things like
making sure that we're killing as many
babies as possible so here's her answer
when she's asked is there any
restriction are there any restrictions
at all on abortion that you would
support here's what she says
any restrictions around abortion that
you would approve of what we have in New
York state is simply a codification of
Roe v Wade so what has been out there
since the Supreme Court before The
Supreme Court
undid 50 years of progress for women so
women like myself and my daughter would
have a right my granddaughter does not
have the same right that I had to make a
determination in concert with myself or
my doctor if it's after the sixth month
so we have the same restrictions and
anyone who says otherwise is just
incorrect
deeply concerned that her daughter or
rather her granddaughter uh won't be
able to kill
babies
this is the sort of thing that she's
worried about
I said most Americans wake up they're
worried about can they afford food can
they put gas in their car are they going
to be safe okay wakes up worried that
her granddaughter won't be able to kill
babies
that her own progeny won't be uh wiped
off the face of the Earth in the womb
that's what she she wakes up middle of
night cold sweats
worried that not enough babies are being
killed now she doesn't answer the
question will you are there any
restrictions you would support she
doesn't answer because the answer is no
of course there are no restrictions
whatsoever uh and that's the cat that is
the mainstream Democrat position on
abortion now no restrictions abortion
right up to the moment of birth and also
afterwards
and this is something that Republicans
need to continue to highlight because
you know what do Democrats want to do
when it comes to abortion they want to
they want to make the entire
conversation centered around the hardest
kinds of cases they want to Center the
entire conversation around the one
percent of abortions that are linked to
you know rape incest allegedly life of
the mother
um although the heavy qualifications on
on those by the way but that's that's
still one percent
even according to
pro-abortion groups like The gutmacher
Institute
even according to their own numbers
we're talking about one percent of
abortions and they want the entire
abortion debate to center around the one
percent of cases
and what Republicans should be doing as
much as possible is saying we're not
before we talk about the one percent of
cases let's deal with the 99 percent of
cases let's deal with the 99 percent of
cases when babies are being killed
surely as a form of birth control
what about that
now you answer all the questions on the
99 of cases
all the questions that the public might
have about that then we could talk about
the one percent but before but we're not
going to talk about the one percent at
all if you can't talk about the 99
all right
um and Kathy hope kills just to
summarize here but remember she did not
she was not a she was not elected
governor the first time
she ended up in that position because
Cuomo got run out of town
and so she's made it all the way to the
governor's mansion
having I don't know she's one maybe one
political race during that time
she is just
road coattails all the way to the
governor's mansion she has a picture of
mediocrity
and this is really who runs the country
I don't mean Kathy hope you'll
specifically
I mean mediocre liberal white women
are really around the country when it
comes down to it
so much of our culture is is run by
people like this
all right moving to uh this from the
daily wire it says chest reconstruction
surgeries performed on minors across the
United States increased by approximately
400 percent during a three-year span
according to a new report
that's 400 percent it does not mean I'm
not I'm not misspeaking 400 percent
the Journal of the American Medical
Association International peer review
journal or general medical journal
published that researchers from
Vanderbilt University in Nashville
Tennessee reported that 1130 chest
mutilating surgeries were performed on
children younger than 18 years old from
2016 to 2019. of those encounters
1114 were mastectomies while 16 were
augmentation mammoplasties bringing the
annual number of child mutilations
during the report of the year to a 389
percent increase
the study noted to our knowledge this
study is the largest investigation to
date of gender affirming chest
reconstruction in a pediatric population
the results demonstrate substantial
increases in gender affirming chest
reconstruction for adolescents
the report noted reconstructive genital
surgery is typically not performed in
adolescence but masculinizing chest
reconstruction mastectomy and feminizing
chest reconstruction augmentation
ramoplasty may be performed in
outpatient and Ambulatory Surgery
settings
so that is a 400 percent increase
and yet we are still told that there is
no social contagion here at work
no social contagion just a 400 increase
um and in some ways you know it's it's
it's easy to get to that 400 increase
because what that also tells you is that
prior to 2016 it's just like it wasn't
happening at all
it it effectively wasn't happening at
all
up until about six or seven years ago
and now it's happening with
I mean to say increasing regularity is
vast understatement
and if we don't do something about this
I mean this is a this is a a trend
trends like this they don't tail off on
their own
especially when you have
powerful institutions that are feeding
the trend
this is not happening by accident
obviously
there's a lot of money behind it and a
lot of money being made on it
and if you don't do something about it
then we if we if we keep with this rate
of growth
10 years from now what does it look like
what percentage of the female adolescent
population 10 years from now will have
been mutilated
I mean the numbers are
jaw dropping
unless we do something about it
and we talk about doing something about
it that's not just fighting in the
culture but that also means laws we need
to be laws passed which of course as you
know is what we're trying to do here in
uh in Tennessee now in other countries
across the world they don't have this
problem Andy Noe has an interview with a
man named balas Orban who's a member of
the administration of Hungarian prime
minister Victor Orban and here they talk
about the Hungarian approach to gender
issues and uh there's quite a lot in
this short clip that's interesting so
listen to this
in the United States
um research is showing that from a
five-year period of 2017 to 2022 the
number of teens and young adults who are
trans identifying had doubled in the
United Kingdom there is a 4 415 increase
in young people seeking gender treatment
since 2009. these are huge I mean this
is a phenomenal
this is happening in your country well
we realized just a couple years ago that
something similar is happening in in
Western Europe and in the United States
but until this moment it was quite an
unknown issue in Hungary we don't have
for example a word
word for gender so what we decided is to
act immediately which for us means that
we should ask the Hungarian people in
all the Strategic issues what do they
think whether they want to go to that
direction which is which is offered by
by the media by the ngos by Brussels or
or they want to find another pattern so
that's why we introduced the referendum
when we asked where we asked for
questions
from the hungarians and with overwhelmed
majority they made the decision that
they they said no to gender propaganda
for minors in schools especially without
the constant of parents and they said no
to gender treatments for minors so what
I can say is that from the country your
medical institutions do not by law
cannot provide
transitioning services or surgical
treatment to mind this is the case and
it's not my opinion as a politician is
the opinion of more than 3.5 million
Hungarian voters and we have to respect
that
they don't even have a word for gender
in Hungarian
and that's the case
many countries in many languages across
the world now they have a word for sex
they they have a word to indicate male
or female
but this other
uh undefinable incoherent category
that's separate from sex but also not uh
is that doesn't exist in the Hungarian
language it doesn't exist in most
languages
I mean arguably any other language
except English because we're the ones
who invented it
but
in in uh in Hungary this isn't this is
an issue this is obvious like of course
we're not going to allow this to happen
to kids and and what this means is that
other countries in the world they are
looking
[Music]
at
us
as a bunch of depraved lunatics
forget about shining City on a Hill
those those days sadly very sadly are
gone those are long gone
other other countries in the world
including other European countries
um
they look at us in their flabbergasted
and not in a good way
they see just uh they they see a culture
that is descended fully into lunacy
and they're right
that's what's so sad about it I can't
even disagree
it is it's shameful it's embarrassing
and as you know as someone who's
actually gone outside of the uh Western
bubble and talked about these issues
with people who exist outside of that
bubble
you know I've experienced this myself
and in what is a woman it leads to a
very interesting footage and and some of
it is quite funny but at the same time
it's humiliating
because I'm an American
and I want to be proud of
my country
it's very difficult to be proud
when you're one of the only countries in
the world
that sexually mutilates kids
all right daily wire has this Meghan
Markle said she's afraid to speak her
mind or be clear about what she needs
for fear of sounding demanding and being
perceived as an angry black woman
during spotify's archetypes podcast on
Tuesday the host uh Markle spoke with
actress Issa Ray in comedian actress
zeeway fumado about her reluctance to be
more assertive the episode was titled
upending the angry black woman myth
um she says I'm particular I think a a
high tide raises All Ships we're all
going to succeed so let's make sure it's
really great because it's a shared
success for everybody
but I know that uh I will find myself
cowering and tiptoeing into a room
and then okay then she goes on to talk
about how she's afraid and every time
she if she speaks up then she'll be an
angry black woman it's all racist and
she's just every day that now because
she has this podcast so every day
there's another headline about her
complaining about something last week it
was she was complaining that she was
objectified because she had a job on
Deal or No Deal where she was uh one of
the chicks holding the the briefcases
apparently she was for like kidnapped
and forced at gunpoint to be a part of
this game show it's not a choice she
made on her own
so every every episode she complains
about something else
Meghan Markle is
she is the embodiment of the sort of
person who never has a good day you know
you ask her how her day was and it's
always stressful it's always too busy
there was always too much traffic the
line was always too long at the grocery
store not that Markle shops for her own
groceries of course I'm gonna say
because she's she's rich and famous and
doesn't do that but she is the Rich and
Famous version of that kind of person
it's not so much focusing on the
negatives
it is that
but even more than that
it is not ever wanting to concede
that something went well that things are
okay
that you had to find time
that you had it that you have it easy
they have a nice life
there are people who just don't want to
admit this no matter what
because many people in our culture today
are addicted to pity
Meghan Markle again she's the embodiment
of this a perfect issues the mascot
someone who's addicted to pity
people that have they've given up on
being loved or being respected or being
admired
they might want those things sort of in
theory
but they can't reach for them
because that means they'd have to give
up the pity
right you can't you can't reach for
greatness
um wanting to be successful and to be
respected and to be admired while also
Clinging On to Your self-pitying you
have to let go of that they can't do it
because pity is a drug to them they're
addicted to it
and that's certainly the case for Meghan
Markle all right I got to move on from
to this quickly because uh I don't want
to run out of time for it again it is
very important as mentioned yesterday I
was alerted this week to a strange set
of circumstances evidently according to
fans of the Hallmark Channel and and
there are still fans of that channel
there's a new Christmas Hallmark movie
that features a character or has a a
cameo appearance of a character briefly
who these fans insist
must be based on me
uh this character is a parody of me I
was told and not and and not a very
flattering one
so I've obtained the footage of this
possible Matt Walsh inspired character I
don't know what we would call this this
is uh this is matte face
this gives us a character in Matt phase
uh we'll go through it and you tell me
what you think by the way I have no idea
what the plot of this movie is to the
extent that Hallmark movies even have
plots I'm not sure it doesn't matter but
we'll just I can't really set this up
but we'll just dive right into it
no I'm so glad you got here before Bert
okay yeah why is that it's no big deal
there's just couple of things you ought
to know before you meet him I'm so sorry
I'm just finding out about all this now
okay like what minor things I mean
nothing horrible
you guys you're making it sound like I'm
being set up with some sort of nut case
no no I don't I I don't know Mark
uh would we call Bert a nut case maybe
more like an outsider what that's not
very convincing
should go check on the roast
Shannon what have you gotten me into he
wasn't even on social media so I
couldn't look him up I know I know I
thought that was refreshing until I
found out why okay and why he's been
banned from all social media platforms
what bands just from spreading
misinformation oh my gosh it's fine he
has a lot of good qualities like he's
single
that's not equality
all right give me a positive second I
just need to take a breather I need to
take a breather because the acting
is so bad this is this is hard to watch
with the with the music in the
background the whole thing
so this is someone banned from social
media for for spreading miseration now
we know that that the Hallmark Channel
has a long since gone woke so this this
is not surprising at all they're
presenting this as just like if
someone's banned from social media
it must be because they actually spread
misinformation
as opposed to the reality of course
which is that when you're you're banned
uh because you have said something that
the left has deemed misinformation
usually because they they can't engage
with it and so they just label it
misinformation and use that as a as a
pretense for getting rid of you no no
surprise that the Hallmark Channel has
adopted the leftist
viewpoint on this uh and also of course
if someone's banned from social media it
means that you should be afraid to uh go
out with them or be around them you know
this is someone only nut cases
would run afoul of the Twitter police if
you run a foul the Twitter police you
must be crazy
all right so they're talking about what
is allegedly the me character and he's
about to make an appearance I think
let's keep watching
[Music]
it's so good
right
I do she's here she's here
I can't believe you're making me do this
you're doing this let's go
wow your house is very clean thanks hi
allow me to introduce you to my lovely
sister that's why I'm here
this is Noel
hi
[Music]
okay no I don't do handshakes there's
germs
um
I would never do that can I get you
something to drink Bert sure something
non-alcoholic and non-carbonated well
that's definitely not any artificial
colors or flavorings or high fructose
corn syrup okay okay so tap water good
is it filtered I'm pretty sure yeah
all right that's fine yeah Mark um I can
have some water as well my mouth
suddenly feels very dry you got it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
are you one of those people who believe
our planet is actually round all right
okay I've seen enough all right
she's got the polka dot shirt beard
glasses
very dry personality
but it looks like the the views that are
being
assigned to this person are not my views
at all
uh especially after after covet I mean
someone who doesn't want to shake hands
because they're afraid of germs that is
very much a leftist thing now
worried about high fructose corn syrup
uh I've never I've never even said the
phrase high fructose corn syrup this is
the first time I've ever even said it
only wants non-alcoholic drinks at a
party that is definitely not me
but at the same time this is Hallmark
right this is their this is their
caricature of so obviously they're
trying to it's a character of somebody
on the right and so they're just
ascribing every nutty opinion to that
person
I don't know I'm not I I I don't have a
verdict on this I will leave it up to
the jury to decide
because you know the other thing is just
because someone has a beard and glasses
and yeah the hairstyle is very similar
I'll give you that
but not everyone with a beard and
glasses looks like me
there are some similar I don't know I'm
in the middle
but I leave it up to you to determine
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shell says I was to start a new job
today and they wanted me to fill out
some paperwork here come the preferred
pronoun and gender questions and then it
actually asked what my sexual
orientation is I promptly refuse to
answer such questions and quit the job
I'm with you Matt I refuse to play their
game the truth does matter
now
I know that uh who cares about silly
things like laws but is it not illegal
to ask
in employees what their sexual
orientation is
am I missing something
Justin says the left you can't yell fire
in a crowded theater also the left pulls
fire alarm in a crowded theater
well it's
a good point dusk deepen says Matt is
very close to acknowledging that
widespread violence is on the horizon a
society has never been this unstable and
managed to avoid a bloody ending
on the horizon
it's not on the horizon but we we have
reached the Horizon my friend we're
already there we already we are
experiencing now widespread violence now
if if what you're referring to is
violence in the form of like a civil war
situation then
you know as I've said before I I think
that's not outside the realm of
possibility that we could have a Civil
War uh I think that our divisions are
deep enough
between the sides that it that it you
know historically
if if history is uh is a precedent here
then it could lean that direction
but for a bunch of other reasons
including the fact that our uh you know
we have these ideological differences
but they're not as cleanly divided on
Geographic lines there obviously are
blue areas and red areas
but um these things intermingle enough
that I that what I would predict is just
well you said widespread
violence pockets of violence increasing
kind of Chaos
in a much more disorganized fashion and
I think that is what we're experiencing
right now
Ken says sorry Matt the person closest
to the window owns the right over the
window shade don't like it buy a window
seat stop crying snowflake
don't tell me what to do first of all I
will cry over this if I want to I will
cry over your faulty logic to begin with
just because you're closest to something
means that you own it
but so if I come to your house
and I sit on your couch I own it
if I'm closest to your dog I own your
dog
if I'm closest to the big fish tank when
I'm taking my kids to the Rainforest
Cafe do I own the fish tank can I take a
fish out of the fish tank for a snack
because the appetizers always take two
and a half hours at Rainforest Cafe can
I do that
think of the consequences of what you're
saying here Ken
speaking of Anarchy think of the Anarchy
that would ensue if we adopted this
principle this is like a child's
understanding of ownership I'm closest
to it so I own it
what kind of ethical framework is that
no the window is on I am as you know
a proponent of equity
and the window is owned the ownership of
the window is is equitable
it is one-third ownership for everybody
in the row
unless I'm closest to it which case I'll
just do whatever I want John John says
uh Matt when are you going to denounce
Ben for shaving his beard was the whole
beard growing thing just a stunt to
promote Jeremy's razors I don't know
what it was
um well I know what it was it was a
betrayal
I thought that Ben had finally been
reformed they had seen the air of his
beardless ways I thought that we the two
of us could finally be co-beardsman
bonded in that sacred
follicle Brotherhood
I was proud of him to tell you the truth
um to be a little vulnerable myself I
was proud of him and then and then one
day without warning
he shaves it off bearing his naked face
to the world it's
it's
indecent
for one thing
men should not be showing off their
naked chins it is it is grotesque we
need to start shaming naked chin like we
shame or used to shame people will show
off other parts of their body I thought
Ben finally understood this so I don't
know
I have nothing to offer here but my
heartbreak I haven't fully processed my
feelings
or come to grips with my trauma but but
thank you for asking
it's been a busy month here at the daily
wire we released the greatest lie ever
sold a new documentary that buries BLM
we held a rally to end child mutilation
of the Tennessee State Capitol and we
are hours away from another exciting
event which is daily wire backstage join
me Ben Shapiro Michael kloe Michael
Coles Michael calls we'll just go with
it Michael Coles Andrew Clavin and God
King Jeremy boring tonight at 6 PM
Central 7 P.M Eastern we'll be taking
we'll be talking about the midterms
leftist meltdowns and a whole lot more
it's a backstage you don't want to miss
so tune in tonight at
dailywireplus.com now let's get to our
daily cancellation
foreign
a fan of you too I don't know if if I've
ever even met a fan of their music I
don't think anyone has ever liked you
two and yet they are one of the most
successful musical acts in the history
of the world it's not clear exactly how
they managed to pull this off they
became you might say the world's
elevator music or maybe society's hold
music something you hear all the time
whether you like it or not and you don't
really like it but you also don't
necessarily hate it the music just is it
exists and it exists everywhere and
nobody knows why and nobody ever asks
and nobody can distinguish one U2 song
from another no one can we all we know
every U2 song and yet we don't know any
of them it's one of the most confounding
riddles of Life The Man Behind this
mystery Bono was profiled yesterday in
the New York Times in a piece titled
Bono is still trying to figure out U2
and himself
it only deepens the mystery to discover
the lead singer of the band also doesn't
know why it exists or why anybody likes
it as for figuring out himself Bono is
in his mid-60s now it's probably time to
start arriving at a few conclusions
before it's too late he's apparently
written a memoir which explains why he
was doing the New York Times interview
most of the interview doesn't interest
me but there is one admission
that did interest me he says this quote
I ended up as an activist in a very
different place from where I started I
thought that if we just redistributed
resources then we could solve every
problem
I now know that's not true
there's a funny moment when you realize
as an activist the off-ramp out of
extreme poverty is
Ugg Commerce it's entrepreneurial
capitalism
imagine that
who could have ever guessed it's
capitalism now I will say that you know
I don't treat capitalism like a religion
as some establishment conservative types
have done historically I believe in the
free market I don't think that our free
market principles though should preclude
us from doing things like regulating big
Tech holding it accountable for the ways
that it censors and suppresses speech I
also don't think that defending the free
market must necessarily mean that we
have to be Ardent Defenders of Behemoth
transnational corporations
the relationship between government
corporations big Tech media the kind of
systemic Human Centipede as I have
previously described it is is is is such
that the phrase free market barely even
applies to these institutions they've
all become like quasi-governmental
institutions in their own way further I
don't think that being a capitalist
means that we must surrender our culture
to smut and filth insisting that any
effort to enforce basic standards of
human decency is somehow an assault on
the free market or on Free Speech so
these are all important caveats and
perhaps caveat isn't the right word they
are more so specifications or
descriptions
of what I mean when I talk about
capitalism and the descriptions are
important because not everyone means the
same thing in fact Bono himself
transitions immediately from admitting
that capitalism is the best way out of
poverty to making a sales pitch for
globalization he conflates the two
globalization and capitalism but they're
not the same thing that is a specific
sort of capitalism the type that a
left-wing multi-millionaire celebrity is
destined to support but it's not the
only option
and in the case of impover impoverished
third world countries what they need
most is not globalization but a
legitimate local economy with thriving
small businesses and so on
so with all that said
um Bono is correct in the fundamental
Revelation at which he has arrived about
60 years late
that the way out of poverty is through
entrepreneurial capitalism
he's wrong though that this is separate
this is somehow a separate concept from
redistributing resources and that's kind
of a false choice because one way or
another resources are going to be if you
want to put it this way redistributed
that's because there are finite
resources available there's a certain
amount of food a certain amount of
houses a cars certain amount of uh
capital in the world there are a lot of
these things and more can be produced
and are produced every day but the
amount is still finite as opposed to
infinite it's just another way of saying
that you can't make all of your
necessities and your desired luxuries
materialize out of thin air if you want
something or you need something you have
to obtain it it must be transferred or
distributed
if you like into your possession
the only other option is to build
Harvest or hunt it yourself but very few
people in the modern world can live an
entirely self-sustaining life and it's
not generally a path to prosperity and
besides even if you go that route you
still need to obtain some of the tools
necessary to do it successfully
so the question becomes not whether
resources are distributed from one party
to another
everyone agrees on that if you want to
have any kind of economy and every civil
civilized society and even uncivilized
ones must have economies
then that's just the nature of the Beast
and broadly speaking here simplifying to
a significant extent
there are two ways
of getting the resources from one party
to another
you can do it by plunder and seizure
which is a stronger Force taking the
resources it wants and giving it to
whoever they determine starting of
course with themselves
or you can do it through a Marketplace
or a one party obtains the desired good
or service from another party and in
exchange pays an agreed upon price
neither of these systems are perfect
both can be abused
there will be poverty in both
unscrupulous people will find ways to
exploit the vulnerable in either case
but the question is which system opens
up the best path to human flourishing
while offering fewer opportunities for
exploitation and depression and the
answer as history has always shown is
the latter
free market approach which offers the
most Freedom the most flourishing
and will be the most likely to lift
people out of poverty
the problem with the Seas and plunder
system whether it's a governmental
entity doing it or Pirates or Vikings or
a rival tribe or whoever is that you're
relying on their benevolence
to identify the parties who need the
resources more and then deliver it
you're also relying on their perfect
wisdom to know who deserves what
you are depending on them to have God's
goodness and generosity and wisdom to go
along with the god-like powers that they
are wielding and that faith is always
100 of the time misplaced this is why
communism and socialism and all forms of
governmental redistribution systems end
in misery and catastrophe
one of the problems with progressives
like Bono is that they don't respect or
understand nature
and that applies to external nature the
planet's nature the nature comprised of
trees and oceans and clouds
it also applies to internal nature Human
Nature they respect and understand that
least of all
they don't understand that human beings
are Fallen creatures and so all of our
institutions will be at some level
broken and unreliable and so we can't
give absolute power to any Institution
the institutions that they can't carry
the weight of that sort of trust and
faith
they also don't understand
Tendencies and Trends and the ways in
which historical Trends can and should
guide our expectations of the future
the left just doesn't understand this
that's why they keep trying to
you know get socialism going again and
again because no matter how much misery
it accounted for in the past it's also
why on the individual level they think
that we ought to continue releasing
violent criminals back in dark
communities maybe they've changed maybe
they've been reformed they cry
yeah maybe
but almost certainly not
Anything is Possible
but we have to make policies and
decisions based on what is probable not
what is possible
it's possible that you could jump off of
a 100 story building and survive I mean
it's it's possible technically
it's not impossible it is possible but
it's certainly not probable
the probability is low enough
that it's worth taking the elevator
even if that's a little bit slower
as for economic systems a common citizen
advocating for governmental control is
like jumping out of that window and
hoping that you're the one guy who has a
positive experience with it
on the other hand for the powerful for
the elite
socialism is not a Plunge at all it's an
elevation to even greater Heights
enjoyed at the expense
of all those peons still lingering at
ground level
and who will soon end up lower even than
that
these are all points quite obvious to me
and to most of you
they were not obvious to Bono until now
I'm glad that he finally got it right
sort of got it right anyway
but unfortunately
for being late to the party
I must still say that he and his music
are canceled
mostly it's just his music though to be
honest that's canceled
all right that'll do it for this portion
of the show as we move over to the
members block hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]